you are just fabulous in this film I
think you need to move to Toronto you
made this film here you had your world
premiere your Montreal doing x-men right
now yeah I think should be Canadian sis
and what do you think I with me yeah I'm
I love Canada I've done like six films
in Toronto - now in Montreal I'm just
waiting for my my get is this an
official invitation yeah you could be
our citizen ad in there when it's Justin
- oh uh pretty nice guy isn't he yeah
yeah he's my political crush yes you
know I have to tell you watching your
video that you posted on Twitter I just
want to say thank you um I think it
reached out to so many people around the
world not just in America what do you
want to see happen next I know it's a
big question but what's the next step
the most important thing is to listen to
each other because right now we have
people that are just screaming what they
believe and they're just getting louder
and louder but when you're not listening
to people mm-hmm then you're never gonna
come to an understanding and you're
never gonna have empathy for others so
that's what I really longed for is for
someone to actually open their ears and
listen yeah and listen and for you to
see Jessica in this role I mean she was
just incredible West was another role
that you thought she was incredible I
think she's seen she's been incredible
in everything that I've seen her do and
I think it's most of the things that
I've seen her do phenomenal and he sees
me in zero dark thirty and in the help
she was nominated for Oscars in both she
was just fantastic in the zookeepers
wife and and in Miss Sloan she is a very
special actress that there aren't two of
ya and she was absolutely who I wanted
to play mahalia I wasn't optimistic that
we'd be able to get her but we did and
it sure paid off how did you ask her I
got down on one knee
there was no choice actually they are
you know we had met before right
like in 2011 or 12 at a party but we met
for this movie had like an official
meeting and at the meeting I said okay I
should be playing this part so what are
we doing right now I don't understand
this right it's true it was very Molly
thing was a Molly and has Molly watched
it she's giving you her approval
yeah Molly last night was our world
premiere yep here at the Toronto
International Film Festival and that was
the first time I saw a movie so she's
here with her family okay uh we um Molly
pled guilty in the United States to a
federal crime which means she is not
allowed to come into Canada
so and obviously we gave her the
opportunity to Isum that she want to see
the movie in private and so we'll set up
a small screening room for you but she
really wanted to see the experience
movie the first time as a member of the
movie audience but she wasn't allowed
into Canada so I engaged the lawyer here
in Toronto who specializes in
immigration and the Canadian government
and their generosity give her a 48-hour
pass which we didn't honestly we didn't
know it was gonna happen until hours
before the premier began but it did so
Molly and her father and the rest of her
family they were in the audience last
night and if if only that happened that
was the only thing that happened with
this movie it would have been worth it
because they were very emotional about
the movie
Wow and they're you know the one thing I
loved about her character Oh said she
had a career before she got down and
then she started another career what was
your career before becoming an actress
and before our director I didn't really
have a career before becoming an actress
I mean I knew I wanted to be an actress
since I knew it was the things one was
and so for me it was always just that
that was my endgame and I was just like
impatient and I was like walking around
like why are you casting kidding and I
just had a survival jobs when I came out
of college move to New York just start
being a struggling writer bussing tables
tending bar handing out leaflets
dressing up like a moose I did I I for
and these are all bit of um wage jobs
and anything that would pay me four
dollars and fifty cents an hour I
dressed up like a moose to hand out
leaflets to the sportsmen show at the
New York Convention Center and like a
fool I thought sportsmen they meant
baseball football basketball the sports
that I like they meant hunting and
fishing which and I don't know those are
two things listen I'm I'm I'm I'm a
hypocrite I'm a vegetarian I'm wearing
leather shoes right now I just don't
like the idea of hunting for sport of
having fun killing an animal but and
there I was dressed up like a moose
handing out these things so as a matter
of protest I was supposed to be saying
come to the Javits Center do this but I
wouldn't say anything
I would only hand out the leaflets so I
was a mute moose for $4.50